- [Voiceover] This is Bertha.
She's a lemur, more
specifically, a coquerel’s sifaka.
While all of Madagascar lemurs are rare,
she's unique even for her kind.
There are over 100 different
types of lemurs in Madagascar.
But none quite like the coquerel’s sifaka.
Found only in the Northwestern
Forest of Madagascar,
sifakas move differently than most lemurs.
They stand on two feet and
use their powerful hind legs
to leap up to 30 feet in a single jump.
Their beautiful fur
also distinguishes them.
Their cream colored bodies
feature maroon patches.
Bertha loves her peanuts but
sifakas aren't picky eaters.
They consume everything
from leaves and flowers
to bark and dead wood.
Biologists estimate that less
than 10,000 remain in the wild
as major habitat laws and
hunting continues to increase.
This is the coquerel’s sifaka.